lui c'est Victor Wemba nyama dans cette
vidéo qui cumule plus de 8 millions de
vues sur le compte Instagram de la NBA
la prestigieuse League américaine de
basket on voit l'arrivée du jeune
sportif français aux États-Unis ce géant
français mesure en 2m21 et âgé de 19 ans
va participer dans la nuit de jeudi à
vendredi à la draft cérémonie durant
laquelle les franchises américaines
sélectionnent les meilleures espoirs du
basket américain et mondial accueille à
l'aéroport de New York ovation au stade
de baseball des Yankees
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un engouement rarement vu pour un futur
arrivant au sein de la NBA c'est que le
natif du Chesnay dans les Yvelines fils
d'une ancienne basketteuse et d'un ex
athlète pourrait pour beaucoup
révolutionner le jeu ce qui rend
wembanyama si spécial sa motricité et
une technique Ball en main incroyable
malgré sa taille pour résumer il joue
comme les petits qui sont généralement
plus mobiles que les grands quand il
avait 50 tout le monde pensait qu'il en
avait 10 et il faisait ma taille 1m70
vers 8 ans s'amuse Emmanuel savarin son
entraîneur chez les poussins à l'entente
Le Chesnay Versailles on se doutait
qu'il allait avoir un corps pour jouer
au basket de haut niveau sa maman fait
un mètre 91 le papa fait 2 m 05
sa taille c'est aussi son problème son
corps est donc plus fragile il peut donc
se blesser ce qui pourrait écourter sa
carrière il va encore beaucoup
progresser et notamment physiquement il
va s'en durcir sans nécessairement
changer beaucoup de morphologie parce
qu'il est plutôt fin et ça fait partie
de ses qualités
formés dans le club de Nanterre dès
l'âge de 10 ans il lui deviendra le
meilleur espoir du championnat de France
en 2021 à 17 ans de 10 à 17 ans de
poussins au plus haut niveau français
j'ai été au meilleur endroit Nanterre et
ma maison ma deuxième famille
cette saison avec le club de Boulogne
Levallois Wayne bagnat a remporté un
nombre impressionnant de récompense
d'individuelles comme celle de meilleurs
joueurs du championnat de France malgré
une défaite en finale face à Monaco déjà
pressenti pour jouer en NBA le phénomène
a rempli les salles françaises durant la
saison écoulée outre-Atlantique certains
le voient même devenir le meilleur
joueur de la NBA d'ici deux ou trois ans
en attendant one banyama devrait sans
véritable surprise être recruté par les
San Antonio Spurs cette nuit la
franchise ou à jouer Tony Parker le
français qui a le mieux percé en NBA
devrait aussi devenir le premier
Français à être sélectionné comme numéro
un d'une draft
[Musique]